so Jonathan's going through he just came
and said that you know he has HIV yes
what was that conversation like and
obviously of course I will say I am so
immensely proud of him using his
platform although this was something
that he felt a need to express that he
really wanted to share with everybody
but I think you know the overarching
message is that he wanted other people
to feel like they were less lonely which
is I think what queer I taught us is
that we're never alone in our struggles
and our in our experiences and so I just
commend him for it and I remember when
he told me and like I've always had
nothing but love for him and I will
continue to have nothing but love for
him like that's what unconditional love
is it's gonna make it rain like
positivity
sunshine cash flow good feeling healing
honey we are the gay weathermen with the
pork a few I can't read yeah now you
guys a lot of you that haven't been
releasing books you Jonathan loosing
book pretty pretty close together no how
do you guys support each other when it
comes to these other projects that we're
doing like we're in this together
yeah we are a boy band of sorts except
we are most of us well into our thirties
but it's what we're going through this
crazy phenomenon together and we get to
experience so much as a unit it's a safe
space where we can talk about with the
different things that we want to pursue
and this platform that we have now with
the visibility and the responsibility
that comes with it you even said
previously that it was more personal
than you expected it to be that is very
true you know we spent a lot of time
and I used a collectively as although
the voices in my head trying to figure
out like what kind of a book I wanted to
produce was it gonna just be an
extension of queer eyes are gonna be
recipes that didn't make it to the
episodes it's gonna be my polish
heritage who that is it as a student
dishes that I prepare on dates and I
realize that it didn't have to just be
one thing I kind of made it everything
and the work that I can really back the
most and get the most excited about is
when it's real and when it's organic the
way that it is unclear I so I wanted to
make like a culinary memoir of like
dishes that shaped me oh wow smell that
so you can smell the alcohols burning
out of the white wine already oh Rudy
notes now can you feel your Croatian
yeah and you get a lot of attention on
your Instagram now I don't know how you
take this but a lot of people will say
oh those for those are like thirst trap
photos what do you think about that
statement I think I feel like basically
you know queer I there's a certain part
of me hmm
a cookbook Antony in the kitchen is
another part of me Instagram anism that
is another one as well I get to do work
endorsements on there I get to play
around with it and have a little bit of
fun and be rebellious
yeah and it's it's like exercising a
different muscle you have to remember to
have fun too and I have fun with it as
well I know what my intentions are and I
like to be funny and entertain myself
and other people and it's like you know
mm-hmm why not